so I'm here to tell everybody to still
pay attention to Iraq until the Iraq is
instrumental for the stability and
welfare of the Middle East and the world
media attention is often only
spotlighted on the rock when there's a
huge crisis we hope that we reduce the
crises and actually get media attention
for successes of moving forward it's
going to be a crucial year 2010 is a
crucial year for Iran with new elections
on the horizon and many aspirations for
Iraqi people to get to a better stage in
their lives it has been a very rough
three decades for the country but we
hope in the coming decades everyone
around the world will continue to help
you rock to get back on his feet my one
wish for 2010 is to have less violence
in Iraq more hope and to give the Iraqi
people the opportunities they truly
deserve